jojo siwa is sparking romance rumors
with her ex-girlfriend kylie prue the
dancer shared these photos of the two at
disney world the first pick shows jojo
holding on tight to kylie as she plants
a kiss on her cheek and check out this
shot jojo laughing in excitement as
kylie tries to pick her up she writes in
the caption quote if you love something
let it go if it comes back next to two
emojis a heart and infinity symbol i
feel awesome jojo and kylie made their
romance instagram official in february
2021 at the time it was their one month
anniversary and while they were together
kylie showed her support for jojo as she
competed on season 30 of dancing with
the stars something jojo was very
grateful for kai is the absolute best i
love her so so so so much i love talking
about this show too kind about this
experience because
she's so supportive
of it so supportive and it it makes my
heart so happy
and
the other night we were watching dancing
with the stars and she was like can we
stop watching these and i was like why
bug and she's like
because it's not you and i want to watch
you dancing but fast forward to october
and the two called it quits
jojo opened up about the split on paris
hilton's podcast but she made it clear
she and her ex were still on good terms
how are you and your love life right now
me and my love life were
we're okay actually i've yet to talk
about this officially publicly but we
broke up
um but she is literally
still my best friend i'm really lucky
that i didn't lose her completely
because you know even though
relationships end
friendships don't have to end then jump
to march and
she's exclusive ladies and gentlemen
exclusive you've heard it here first i'm
not single
i am not single and i don't want to
mingle um no i'm a lawyer lately
it's messy yeah jojo revealed she's in a
relationship she didn't name names but
she told e.t the following month she's
feeling great about it i am in a
relationship and i'm i'm very i'm very
happy and very lucky to be loved it's
been it's been very nice i think
something that's been great is
it's been so honest
and i i think that's a mistake that i've
made in the past is you know maybe just
like
trying to be something that i maybe
wasn't um
but but but this is just so pure and so
honest and it's so real
and it just feels so
it feels like
like i slash we got it right now it's
still unclear if that new relationship
is with kylie or someone else but one
thing's for sure we love to see jojo
happy
[Music]